[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal
préparé par la rédaction de tv 78 nous
sommes le mardi 26 mai voici les titres
de l'actualité locale le lancement d'un
nouveau dispositif sport santé culture
civisme a pour objectif de proposer aux
élèves des activités éducatives sur le
temps scolaire en complément du travail
en classe ou à la maison
la rectrice de l'académie de versailles
était ce matin aux mureaux pour signer
une convention en ce sens avec la
commune en cette période de
déconfinement le trafic des transports
en commun revient un peu à peu à la
normale les bus notamment ont dû revoir
leur fonctionnement depuis le début de
la crise sanitaire exemple dans ce
journal avec le réseau stibus à saint
quentin en yvelines
enfin l'événement solidaire revient pour
une deuxième édition les coureurs ont du
coeur se déroule pendant tout le
week-end de la pentecôte est les profits
de cette opération seront reversés
intégralement à unicef france
interview à partir du mois de juin il
sera effectif dans plusieurs écoles
maternelles et élémentaires des yvelines
deux aces de ses ports aux sports santé
culture civisme un outil pédagogique
adapté à la réouverture progressive des
écoles ce matin à la rectrice de
l'académie de versailles charline avenel
s'est rendu aux mureaux pour présenter
le dispositif
les détails avec ce reportage de
mathilde et demi et de nicolas landry ce
qui a des copines qui te manque pièce
que tu aimerais kerviel nour a fait
partie des huit élèves présents ce mardi
26 mai dans l'école maternelle pierre
brossolette des mureaux avec le respect
des gestes barrières écriture coloriage
et jeux de construction sont au
programme
habituellement ils sont 102 enfants
accueillis chaque jour dans cet
établissement
ce qui est important c'est qu'il
retrouve les les personnes de l'école
qu'il retrouve les enseignants qui leur
trouvent les pratiques pédagogiques
qu'ils avaient et que
ils puissent refaire ce qu'il avait fait
avec leurs parents avec les enseignants
pour faire revenir les élèves et assurer
une continuité pédagogique pour tous
dans les écoles maternelles et primaires
le dispositif deux aces de ces sports
santé et culture civisme a été lancé par
l'état des activités éducatives en
complément du travail scolaire
l'intérêt c'est d'abord du lien du lien
collectif c'est un immense moyens de
ramener les élèves vers l'école ça nous
prépare également à ce qui se passera
pendant les vacances parce qu'on ne va
pas laisser les élèves et les jeunes et
les enfants pendant ses vacances sans
contact sans activité et sans vacances à
prenante puisque nous y travaillons la
commune des mureaux a signé ce
partenariat à partir du 9 juin les
élèves de la ville auront deux jours
d'enseignement et deux jours d'ateliers
deux aces de ces avec plusieurs
activités en collaboration avec des
associations de la ville on a une
association qui est le fils du
développement durable ans qui va
intervenir sur tout ce qui est là liés à
l'environnement notamment la gestion de
l'eau la gestion de la terre
on est en train de regarder aussi avec
des associations de danse qui ne sont
pas nécessairement dans le centre d
heure
d'autres communes comme guyancourt
fontenay-le-fleury poissy et versailles
ont déjà contacté l'académie pour
bénéficier du dispositif
en marge de ce déplacement la rectrice
de l'académie de versailles a fait
également un premier bilan de la
réouverture progressive des écoles dans
le département entre 20 et 30 % des
élèves yvelinois sont revenus dans les
classes écoute et on a réussi plusieurs
choses on a réussi le travail avec les
maires pour la mise en oeuvre du
protocole sanitaire et la quasi totalité
et communes des yvelines sont réouverts
leur école on a réussi le pari des
enseignants puisque on a quasiment 70 %
d'enseignants qui sont aujourd'hui en
présentiel et je dois dire qu'on n'a
peut-être pas tout à fait encore réussi
le fait de donner confiance complètement
aux familles et de pouvoir les ramener
vers l'école c'est ce qui nous préoccupe
aujourd'hui les enfants ont besoin de
revenir à l'école et puisqu'on parle
éducation 11 projets ont été primés
aujourd'hui en cérémonie virtuel sur
twitter elle le concours non au
harcèlement a livré son palmarès 2020 il
a pour but de donner la parole aux
jeunes sur ce phénomène qui touche
environ 700 mille élèves en france est
des supports étaient à produire sur le
sujet parmi les lauréats de nombreux
yvelinois on retrouve notamment les
affiches les collégiens de guillaume
apollinaire à plaisir et de sainte
thérèse à rambouillet le prix cyber
harcèlement revient lui au collège
charles péguy du chesnay rocancourt le
prix spécial harcèlement sexistes et
sexuelles pour cette vidéo est des
jeunes du collège des prés à montigny le
bretonneux en ce qui concerne le prix
des élémentaires il a été attribué à
l'école des hirondelles à aulnay sur
mauldre enfin le coup de coeur
académique a été décerné aux lycéens
d'evariste galois à sartrouville
bravo à tous les participants et aussi
aux lauréats dans l'actualité politique
un nouveau président pour les
hauts-de-seine seul candidat georges
siffredi a été lui hier lundi par les
conseillers départementaux alto
séquanais 38 voix pour les huit membres
de l'opposition n'ayant pas pris part au
vote
le maire de châtenay malabry succède à
patrick devedjian décédé le 29 mars
dernier de lakovic 19
l ancien premier vice-président assuré
d'ailleurs l'intérim à la tête du 92
depuis cette disparition
dans son discours d'investiture georges
siffredi a précisé que son mandat serait
dans la continuité de son prédécesseur
et notamment sur la poursuite de la
fusion avec les yvelines pour rappel
depuis 2016 les deux départements aube
entamé un rapprochement avec la
mutualisation déjà de plusieurs services
et compétences
un dossier qui tenait à coeur à patrick
devedjian et qui va pouvoir aller de
l'avant de quoi réjouir le président du
conseil départemental des yvelines
pierre bédier l'art nouveau président
forcément
peut voir des choses différemment je
sais que j'en ai assez attachés à cette
ce rapprochement
mais les difficultés que l'épidémie a
suscité dans nos économies locales et
c'est peut-être donner d'autres
priorités aujourd'hui ce qui est certain
c'est que georges siffredi moi même
sommes dans l'état d'esprit de gens qui
veulent approfondir la coopération pour
ces deux départements parce qu'elle est
de notre point de vue est essentielle
pour l'ouest parisien et plus
globalement d'ailleurs pour la région
parisienne donc pour la france donc ça
veut dire que le travail a peut-être des
gens qui le rend très vite sur sion
venait normalement nous voyons vendredi
avec jacques qui a été élu hier entre
une longue réunion de travail pour faire
le point sur pino dossier et dossier
passer les dossiers présents et à venir
voilà pour cette réaction suite à
l'élection de georges siffredi à la tête
du département des hauts de seine
politique toujours après montigny le
bretonneux est mort parce c'était au
tour de coignières hier d'installer son
conseil municipal en raison de la crise
sanitaire il s'est déroulé à huis clos à
la maison de voisinage
tout avait été mise en place pour
respecter les gestes barrières et didier
fischer qui avait été élu en décembre
2018 suite à la démission de jean-pierre
sevestre a été réélu par son conseil
municipal les huit adjoints ont
également été désignés les propos
recueillis par aurélien aux enchères
encore c'est malheureusement cette crise
sanitaire et ce qui retarde quand même
assez considérablement les projets que
l'on voulait lancer
dans l'immédiat alors pour l'instant on
est sur la lancée de ce que nous avions
pu faire je dirais dans la mandature
précédente là on va achever le gymnase
on espère pouvoir inaugurer notre
gymnase au mois de septembre mais rien
n'est gagné 1
ensuite on termine et on va terminer
aussi l'agrandissement du cimetière on
pense pouvoir travailler en commun on
verra dans les commissions en tout cas
on espère que ça avance en là on a un
petit peu on a été un petit peu frustré
de ses 2 - avec kobe d'où l'opposition à
paulhe trop son mot à dire
on a eu ce petit besoin de d'information
on n'a pas eu pendant ces deux mois on
espère que ça va être résolue dans les
prochains concerts premier conseil
municipal post élection également ce
lundi à saint cyr l'école les élus se
sont réunis au théâtre gérard philipe
pour installer maires et adjoints
successeur de bernard de bain l'an passé
sonia bros a été réélu pour un deuxième
mandat dans la ville elle avait
recueilli au premier tour 55,6 % des
suffrages face à l'idée du long pont qui
prend la tête de l'opposition composée
de sept membres sur 33 conseillers en ce
qui concerne les villes qui ne sont pas
parvenus à désigner un maire dès le
premier tour le 15 mars dernier à un
deuxième tour des élections municipales
doit se tenir le 28 juin prochain sauf
si la crise sanitaire ne le permet pas
aux clayes-sous-bois la maire sortante
udi véronique côté millard a décidé de
soutenir son premier adjoint philippe
guiguen en tête après le premier tour
l'élu qui n'est pas candidate pour un
nouveau mandat était pourtant sur la
liste d'une autre adjointe anne claire
frémont arrivé troisième le 15 mars
dernier avec 24 16% des voix
un revirement de position expliqué par
le risque de voir la ville a basculé à
gauche le conseiller municipal
d'opposition de gauche nicolas us est
effectivement classé en seconde position
au premier tour à 6.2 philippe guiguen
et nicolas ua a appelé d'ailleurs
stéphanie jamin candidate en quatrième
position à le rejoindre pour le second
tour
le point à présent sur la crise
sanitaire du coronavirus dans les
yvelines deux décès supplémentaires ont
été enregistrés entre dimanche et lundi
l épidémie qui a fait à 479 victimes
dans le département aux dernières
données publiées
hier le nombre d'hospitalisations sur le
territoire s'établissait à 592 soit 19
patients en moins 24 heures le nombre de
réanimation reste stable
enfin 1853 personnes sont désormais
guéri de lakovic 19 dans les yvelines
après un passage à l'hôpital activités
essentielles le transport de passagers
n'a jamais cessé et ce même pendant la
période de confinement mais depuis le 17
mars et de nouvelles règles sont apparus
pour les conducteurs comme pour les
usagers sur le réseau et ski bus le
fonctionnement a été revu mélanie poker
combinaisons masques et machines
philippe va passer les prochaines
minutes à désinfecter un bus dont le
service est terminée il pulvérise un
virus il dans une cinquantaine de
véhicules chaque jour du haut vers le
bas puisque ça c'est sensé pulvérisé
donc de fines particules de produits de
façon à ce que ce dernier repose sur
l'echez enfin les dossiers toutes les
rangs plein tient que pourrait utiliser
un passager lorsque celui ci monte dans
le car c'est un produit qui est tenu
d'être efficace pendant 24 heures et
ainsi de suite
une désinfection jusqu alors inédite les
transporteurs yvelinois s'y sont mis dès
l'apparition de l'épidémie ski bus le
complète avec des gestes barrières la
mobilisation est associé avec un
nettoyage manuel jusqu'à la semaine
dernière ont monté par la porte arrière
et on descendait par les portes arrière
et depuis ce matin on a remis une
circulation normale dans le véhicule au
monde par la porte avant et on descend
par les portes arrière et on a condamné
un siège sur deux pour faire respecter
la distanciation nécessaire et on a
indiqué au sol aussi par le moyen de
petits stickers les espaces
un maître pour que chacun puisse avoir
une indication elle la capacité des
véhicules est réduite à une vingtaine de
places 6 quibus maintient aujourd'hui
95% de son offre la fréquentation n'est
toujours pas revenu à la normale
seulement 25 % des usagers ont repris le
chemin des transports en commun c'est
une action sportive et solidaire du 30
mai au 1er juin pendant le week-end de
la pentecôte se déroulera la deuxième
édition des coureurs ont du coeur un
événement au profit d'unicef france et
pour en parler avec moi deux invités
anne avril bonsoir doucet directrice
générale adjointe d'unicef france et
également avec nous samuel bonaudo
bonsoir bonsoir et de sb consult vous
êtes l'organisateur de la course déjà
malgré le contexte un ce contexte
sanitaire que l'on connaisse c'est une
évidence pour vous de reproposer cette
édition une deuxième édition des
coureurs ont du coeur cette année après
la première opération qu'on a mis en
place au début mais ce n'est pas
forcément notre voeu de le faire une
deuxième opération mais on a eu en a
qu'un petit sondage par rapport à nos
participants et 99 % des participants de
la première édition nous demander de me
reconduire une deuxième opération donc
sous cette île dans deux on va dire de
motivation on a on a reconduit une
seconde opération et qu'il y avait alors
les coureurs pourront parcourir des
distances d'un 5 ou 10 km en formule
aussi speed treille sur 1h30 ou en
enduro treille sur trois heures voilà
plusieurs parcours qui sont proposés et
vous inciter à bien respecter les
mesures gouvernementales la
distanciation physique notamment tout à
fait aujourd'hui les règles ont changé
par rapport à la première édition
mais il ya quand même encore des règles
bien entendu il ya des zones encore
interdite au public donc la main tendue
or on n'hésite pas du tout et on demande
aux participants de respecter ses
hésitations et aussi de respecter les
zones distance station parfois ans rocco
voix lors d'un des petits groupes de 10
personnes maximum avec pas mal de
doki contrainte mais qui semble beaucoup
plus souple que sur la première édition
c'est pour ça que l'on imagine les
dissonances déroule sur plusieurs jours
et sans horaires précis 1 c'est vraiment
pour ne pas créer on peut dire
d'attroupement qui est plusieurs
coureurs en même temps sur le même
parcours oui tout à fait à 3 jours pour
le faire un peu le matin le midi le soir
chacun trouve son créneau le plus haut
possible et le plus facile est bien
entendu ça ne viendra pas souvent les
pouvoirs en arrive dans les communes
cours au même endroit anne avril qu'elle
est d'importance de ce genre d'événement
pour unicef france qui on le rappelle
oeuvre à la protection des enfants les
plus vulnérables cet événement a une
double vocation le premier c'est que je
pense de rap et au clic une xf besoin de
courage pour intervenir dans cette crise
jean marais dans quelques instants
et puis c'est aussi une attraction où
des gardes de la cause des enfants et
que est ce que cette crise pardon du coc
vie de 19 à fragiliser davantage la
situation des enfants en france puisque
là on parle de la france mais aussi dans
le monde
absolument cette crise alors les enfants
n'étaient pas les premières victimes et
leader de cette crise mais elle a fait
beaucoup de victimes caché chez les
enfants notamment les enfants les plus
vulnérables en france voit jamais et
puis les big wheel ou situation de
précarité extrême et avec notre
partenaire action où la france est
attachée justement aller chercher ce
pourquoi aller chercher ces familles
vulnérables et à la fournir des sapins
des kits d'hygiène tout ce qu'ils
cherchent
pourquoi pour beaucoup de ces familles
avec une autre notre première action que
j'ai des filles est ensuite intervenu
aussi on va sur l éducatif dans des
conditions très difficiles en parle pas
parce que la droite et le droit à la
connexion n'est pas totale pour tous à
l'international et à l'international
à l'international où évidemment c'est
une cache un petit peu différente selon
les pays
façonnable dans 190 pays mais lalanne
est le principal c'est le sait le retard
de soins accepte cette catastrophe à
cette pandémie notamment dans la
vaccination dans l'accès aux soins dans
l'accès à la santé prénatal et on estime
que ça pourrait causer la mort de 6000
enfants c'était le cas chaque jour je
sais pas s'il existe le textile un
prochain qu on précise je les ai pas dit
au début de cette interview que
l'intégralité des frais de participation
c'est à dire 5 euros par coureur sera
reversée à l'unicef france quels types
d'actions vont pouvoir être financée
grâce grâce à ses dons alors déjà que de
façon très concrète du matériel du
matériel de protection en france je
pense qu'on a un petit des besoins mais
on s'assurera que les personnes à qui on
en a distrait la chaîne
d'approvisionnement pour toutes on
continuera notre ailleurs distribués aux
hôpitaux parisiens
et puis évidemment l'international ce
seront essentiellement d'hygiène des
masques et évidemment tout son matériel
de protection connaissent les soignants
ont besoin et dont ils manquent
réellement une nouvelle audience au
début de cette pandémie
et si on fait l'état des lieux des dons
est ce que en cette période sanitaires
ils ont été en recul peut-être d'autres
d'autres causes peut-être des des
hôpitaux qui ont été aussi financé
pendant cette période puisque les dons
pour unicef france ont été en recul
pendant cette période sanitaires alors
écoutez non non non et je suis très très
heureux comme toujours et les français
ont manifesté un élan de solidarité en
scanner également les personnels
soignants qui était un premier un ring
et c'est tout à fait normal mais une au
premier les enfants combien l'action ni
sa faisait peut-être un peu plus dans
l'ombre ils n'ont pas abandonné leur
soutien pour des enfants à
l'international est de constater on va
dire
est assez comparable 2,3 hier aux années
précédentes on a commencé cette
interview avec vous samuel bonaudo
valeurs terminent avec vous il ya déjà
cinquante neuf inscrits sur le
département des yvelines qui nous
intéressent directement très
concrètement comment s'inscrit ton et
surtout comment participent tous à ceux
à cet événement alors pour rappel en
peul participer en courant ou en
marchant allait beaucoup de marcheurs le
randonneur ou marcheurs sur la première
révision et pour vous engager vous allez
sur le site les coureurs ont du coeur
point com et vous aurez tous les
renseignements pour pouvoir vous engager
les inscriptions sont bien entendu
ouverte
et oui c'est vrai car l'ile-de-france
m'a énormément de participants sur la
première édition c'était la région qui
était le plus représenté votre
département 18 est un des départements
les plus sûrs et plus dynamique
la première édition donc on va voir
faire la deuxième est et comment quels
sont les objectifs pendant que vous fixé
pour pour cette deuxième édition a été
21000 un peu plus de vingt mille
participants sur la première on espère
qu'à minima chaque participante qui
avait couru la première addition puisse
ramener une personne qui l'avait pas
fait donc on aimerait bien mais a minima
du blé la personne c'est notre challenge
aujourd'hui voilà aujourd'hui ça ne va
pas mais comme la première fois et ça va
se mobiliser d'ici la fin de la semaine
donc mettez vos baskets pour aller
marcher courir km 5 km 10 km trail pour
des spécialistes pour avoir le maximum
et pourvoir aux gars et le bâtiment
cet essai tout prochainement c'est du 30
mai au 1er juin toutes les informations
à retrouver sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci en avril merci samuel bonaudo
d'avoir été avec nous mais notre avis
pas si au revoir merci voix pour
refermer ce journal de nombreux
festivals sont annulés depuis plusieurs
semaines en raison de l'épidémie du
coronavirus à mantes-la-jolie les halls
factory festival pourrait être le
premier grand rendez vous culturel dans
les mois à venir les doit se tenir du 18
20 septembre avec une programmation très
éclectique les précisions de mélanie
poker trois jours trois scènes et 20
concerts les chiffres clés pour profiter
d'un coin d'herbe et de musique
pour sa deuxième édition toujours
maintenu pour l'heure le festival et le
factory met en avant son patrimoine de
factures d'instruments ya aussi ce côté
a pas de barrière pas de frontières
entre les styles de musique souvent on
repère un festival par rapport à son
étiquette jazz son étiquette musiques
actuelles ou son étiquette musique
classique nous on a envie de valoriser
le tout de valoriser les musiciens de
valoriser la pratique musicale et donc
et même de favoriser les ponts entre ces
différentes disciplines
grande amatrice de jazz la cantatrice
natalie dessay relève le défi d'une
création avec le duke orchestra sont
aussi annoncés kassav et les têtes
raides une organisation possible grâce
au nombre de personnes autorisées
le festival ne vise pas la limite des
cinq mille personnes les équipes
planchent sur plusieurs scénarii
possibles pour l'instant on parle
beaucoup de du placement des personnes
des distanciation de recours à certaines
pratiques d'hygiène aussi de nettoyage
des différents éléments
on parle aussi de distribution de gel
hydroalcoolique pourquoi pas de de
masques etc
enfin tout ce qui est qui fait partie
maman finalement de notre quotidien
le festival pourrait être une double
fête le 20 septembre montrent la jolie
devrait aussi être synonyme du départ de
la dernière étape du tour de france 2020
après avoir applaudi le pô le ton
pourquoi ne pas applaudir les artistes
avant de vous quitter cette information
avec ses deux réouverture à jouy en
josas le musée de la toile de jouy et la
maison léon blum sont de nouveau
accessibles au public des mesures ont
été tout de même mise en place pour le
musée de la toile de jouy port du masque
obligatoire maximum de dix visiteurs
simultanément sens de circulation pour
la visite
tout comme pour la maison léon blum où
il est nécessaire de prendre rendez vous
du lundi au vendredi porter un masque
qui est recommandé deux à quatre
personnes seulement sont autorisés en
simultané dans chaque pièce pour un
total de est dix personnes sur le site
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi très belle soirée à
tous sur tv 78
[Musique]